Caitlyn Jenner calls out Rob Kardashian
for posting naked pics of blac chyna on
the Internet Rob was stupid for doing
that
[Music]
while the rest of the kardashian-jenner
czar staying tight-lipped about robbing
China's drama Catelyn is speaking her
mind on Friday the 67 year old stopped
by the view and threw shade at the
reality star for sharing explicit photos
of his ex-fiancee on social media last
week Rob a stupid for doing that he kind
of apologized guys I know I used to be
over on that that can be really stupid
okay and and do stupid things and you
really have to and I've tried to warn my
kids I finally pick your friends wisely
but Caitlyn who was married to Rob's
mother Kris Jenner for more than two
decades admitted she hasn't spoken to
her stepson in a while I've never met
blac Chyna and never met the kid Rob I
haven't really had a serious
conversation with in years on Monday a
judge granted Chyna a temporary
restraining order against Rob I would
like to first and foremost thank the
judge for granting me this restraining
order to protect me and I'm just gonna
get back to co-parenting dreams now a
source close to the Kardashians tells et
that the 30 year olds regrets his
actions quote Rob realizes that he
messed up
he knows that sharing those pictures and
videos of China was a terrible thing
mostly as a father this was a good
lesson for him
you